so here's another point so
this is again these are a little bit
mind twisting in some ways but but the
the the um um okay another thing that's
sort of we know
from computation is this idea of
computation universality
the fact that given that we have a
program that runs on one kind of
computer
we can as well you know we can convert
it to run on any other kind of computer
we can emulate one kind of computer with
another
so that might lead you to say well you
think you have the rule for the universe
but you might as well be running it on a
turing machine because we know we can
emulate
any computational rule on any kind of
machine
and that's essentially the same thing
that's being said here that is
that what we're doing is we're saying um
these different
interpretations of physics correspond to
essentially running physics
on different underlying you know
thinking about the physics as running in
different with different underlying
rules
as if different underlying computers
were running them
and but that because of computational
universality
or more accurately because of this
principle of computational equivalence
thing
of mine there's that they are um
these things are ultimately equivalent
so the only thing that is
the ultimate fact about the universe the
ultimate fact that doesn't depend on any
of these
you know we don't have to talk about
specific rules etc etc etc the ultimate
fact is
the universe is computational and it is
the the things that happen in the
universe are
the kinds of computations that the
principle of computational equivalence
says should happen
now that might sound like you're not
really saying anything there
but you are because you can you could in
principle have a hyper computer
that things that take an ordinary
computer an infinite time to do the
hyper computer can just say oh i know
the answer
it's this immediately what this is
saying is
the universe is not a hyper computer
it's not
simpler than a an ordinary turing
machine type computer
it's exactly like an ordinary turing
and so that's the that's in the end the
sort of net net
conclusion is that's the thing that is
the sort of
the hard immovable fact about the
universe that's sort of the
the fundamental principle of the
universe is that it is
computational and not
hyper-computational and not sort of
infra-computational it is
this level of computational ability and
it's um and it kind of has and that's
sort of the
the core fact but now you know this this
idea that you can have these different
kind of uh rule reference frames these
different description languages for the
universe
it it makes me you know i used to think
okay
you know imagine the aliens imagine the
extraterrestrial intelligence thing
you know at least they experience the
same physics right and now i've realized
this isn't true
they could have a different rule frame
that's fascinating
they can end up with a a a description
of the universe that is utterly utterly
incoherent with ours
yeah and that's also interesting in
terms of how we think about
well intelligence the nature of
intelligence and so on you know i'm i'm
fond of the quote you know the weather
has a mind of its own
because these are you know these are
sort of computationally that
that system is computationally
equivalent to
the system that is our brains and so on
and what's different is we don't have a
way to understand
you know what the weather is trying to
do so to speak we have a story about
what's happening in our brains
we don't have a sort of connection to
what's happening there so we actually
it's funny last time we talked maybe
over a year ago uh we talked about
how it was more based on your work with
a rival
uh we talked about how would we
communicate with alien intelligences
can you maybe comment on how we might
how the wolfram physics project changed
your view how we might be able to
communicate with alien intelligence
like if they showed up is it possible
that
because of our com comprehension
of the physics of the world might be
completely different
we would just not be able to communicate
here's the here's the thing you know
intelligence is everywhere
the fact this idea that there's this
notion of oh there's going to be this
amazing extraterrestrial intelligence
and it's going to be this unique thing
it's just not true
it's the same thing you know i i think
people will realize this
about the time when people decide that
artificial intelligences
are kind of just natural things that are
like human intelligences
they'll realize that that
extraterrestrial intelligences
or intelligences associated with
physical systems and so on
it's all the same kind of thing it's
ultimately computation it's all the same
it's all just computation and the issue
is can you
are you sort of inside it are you are
you thinking about it
do you have sort of a story you're
telling yourself about it
and you know the weather could have a
story it's telling itself about what
it's doing
we just it's utterly incoherent with the
stories that we tell ourselves based on
how our brains work
i mean ultimately it must be uh a
question whether we can
align exactly align with the kind of
intelligence
right right so that's the systematic way
of doing it right so the question is in
the space of all possible intelligences
what's the how do you think about the
distance between description languages
for one intelligence versus another and
needless to say i have thought about
this
and uh um you know i i don't i don't
have a great answer yet but but i think
that's a
that's a thing where there will be
things that can be said and there'll be
things that where you can sort of
start to characterize you know what is
the translation distance
between this you know version of the
universe or this
you know kind of set of computational
rules in this other one in fact
okay so this is a you know there's this
idea of algorithmic information theory
there's this question of sort of what is
the uh when you have
some something what is the sort of
shortest description you can make of it
where that description could be saying
run this program to get the thing
right so i'm pretty sure that
that the um uh that
there will be a physicalization of the
idea of algorithmic information
and that okay this is again a little bit
bizarre but
so i mentioned that there's the speed of
light maximum speed of information
transmission and physical space
there's a maximum speed of information
transmission in brass shield space which
is a maximum entanglement speed
there's a maximum speed of information
transmission in rule space
which is has to do with a maximum speed
of translation
between different uh description
languages
and again i'm i'm not fully wrapped my
brain around this one yeah that one
just blows my mind to think about that
but that starts getting closer to the
yeah the kind of intelligence right
it's a and it's also a physicalization
of of algorithmic information and i
think there's probably a connection
between
i mean there's probably a connection
between the notion of energy and some of
these things
which again i i you know hadn't seen all
this coming i i've always been a little
bit resistant to the idea of connecting
physical energy
to things in in computation theory but i
think that's probably coming
you